so let's finally talk about the
performance of this thing right here the
RTX 4090 and yeah it is truly insane
like the kind of frames that this thing
is pushing out at like 4K Max Graphics
yeah you won't believe the numbers are
until you see them so we've already gone
over the exterior design and how this is
different and talk about the specs and
everything like that today we are solely
focusing on the performance and the
benchmarks now the first Benchmark that
I ran for the 4090 was this right here
Forza Horizon 5 running 4K completely
maxed out and I mean I had to double
check that I wasn't running lower
settings or messed something up here but
no this is real this is the new 4090
literally doubling the performance of
the 3090 this is also without any
retracing dlss or anything like that
just pure rendering output and it's
pretty insane then I switched over to
God of War also 4K here at the highest
possible settings and again no Ray
tracing or dlss just yet we'll get to
that in just a minute but I mean just
look at the brute output of this GPU
it's so much higher than I expected
without those RTX effects enabled here
we're looking at about an 80 increase
over the RTX 3090 and it's not far off
triple the performance of a 2080 TI
which is still a strong GPU by today's
standards games that might have been
previously demanding at 4K even on last
gen Flagship gpus they're just not even
remotely challenging for the 4090 Dying
Light 2 for example the 2080 TI does
struggle a bit you'd probably need to
lower some settings and the 3090 just
delivers a 60fps plus experience the new
RTX 4090 though I mean it's kind of
almost laughable at how fast it actually
is now if that wasn't ridiculous enough
here's the new OverWatch 2 running at 4K
with medium settings and there were
multiple times here where the 4090 hits
the in-game frame rate limit of 600 FPS
again that's at 4K now of course those
kind of frame rates they're possible at
lower resolutions with weaker gpus and
lower settings but again just Flex the
role rendering power of the 4090 it's
pretty nuts Nvidia are always kind of
secretive about the gains of
rasterization only performance when they
announce these gpus and that causes
people to kind of speculate that the
performance gains aren't that much but
as you can see they are still pretty
substantial without even factoring in
Ray tracing or dlss so in the end when
we're looking at pure rasterization
output we're averaging close to double
the performance of the RTX 3090 at 4K
that means that most of the time you're
actually hitting over 150 FPS with maxed
out settings and in some cases you're
actually going beyond what the fastest
4K monitors are possible of displaying
so yeah I really meant it when I said
this thing is insane like you just won't
actually believe the benchmarks until
you actually see them and they're just
mind-boggling to see 4K running at those
kind of frame rates especially with
maxed out settings talking about
settings let's now talk about retracing
and dlss and the thing about these
features is they're no longer really
considered Niche or special special
features for one the amount of games
that actually support RTX and Ray
tracing and stuff like that is a huge
list of games like most modern games
coming out will have these features
implemented and secondly I've also seen
some games have these settings enabled
by default like if you go and select
high or ultra high you will actually
have to intervene and turn off Ray
tracing because that's what the
developer has put in as an ultra high
setting so as you'd expect with more RT
cores and tensor cores on the 4090 as
well as just being more powerful in
general switching on RTX leaves the 4090
with a much more capable experience here
we're looking at control running at 4K
everything maxed out including Ray
tracing and also with dlss set to the
balanced mode the RTX 4090 has a new
trick though and that's a DLS S3 feature
called frame generation in a nutshell
what this is doing is comparing two
frames that have already been rendered
and it uses AI to make a completely new
one in between them essentially it's
artificially increasing your frame rate
by inserting AI my fake generated frames
and as you can see the frame rate
increases by doing this even over the
increase by you know using dlss in
performance mode is really really strong
in the end it's about a 50 bump here in
cyberpunk which is Comfortably running
at around 140 FPS now when you take a
look at how much frame rate cheating is
kind of happening here it's pretty
insane with Max settings and Ray tracing
enabled over on the left there you can
get a grasp of how demanding graphically
these settings actually are without any
AI generated frames or AI upscaling
techniques with dlss and the new frame
generation though you're effectively
getting over triple the frame rate one
of the coolest Parts about this though
is that you can kind of cheat your way
past CPU bottlenecks Microsoft flight
simulator for example has a massive CPU
bottleneck but here it is somehow
running at over 200 frames per second
now look it's pure Overkill here with
the 4090 like no one needs to be playing
this game at 4K at these frame rates but
when this feature triggers down to the
lower end cards that on is capable at 4K
or 1440p that's a bit of a game changer
for certain games for those wondering as
well it is also possible to run the new
frame generation feature without any
form of dlss upscaling and the frame
rate boosts there by running it alone is
still pretty strong so frame generation
is pretty interesting and we'll get to
my personal thoughts on it in just a
second I did quite a bit of playing with
it in cyberpunk but you know aside from
it not giving you perfect frames all the
time which to be honest you don't really
notice if you're like playing through
the game quite fast it's really only
something that you notice if you're like
recording gameplay and then you go back
to kind of pixel peep the frames
otherwise if you're just playing through
you really don't notice those AI
generated frames and that kind of
simulation the other thing though which
you do definitely notice with this
feature is the increase in input lag in
flight simulator for example there is a
massive 46 bomb to frame rate as we saw
but there's also a pretty big jump in
latency in this case it's almost double
compared to just enabling dlss cyberpunk
was wasn't as bad but still a pretty
considerable increase about plus 12
milliseconds here over just using dlss
so although dlss upscaling provides both
a frame rate increase and latency
decrease frame generation also gives you
a frame rate buff but at the same time
increasing latency so having this in
mind I actually played cyberpunk for a
bit with this feature I'd switch between
frame generation on versus off trying to
get an honest feel for the actual
experience differences with and without
assetting as opposed to kind of just
looking at the numbers and yeah the
increase in input lag you can feel it I
think it's most noticeable on mouse and
keyboard if you're like intentionally
trying to notice it and you're switching
the setting on and off if you're playing
on controller though it's definitely
less noticeable and I think the style of
games that frame generation is more
suited towards that kind of makes sense
The increased latency it is still there
on controller but not as bad what is way
more noticeable in my opinion though
which is a pretty easy trade-off for me
is that massive boost in frame rate
especially in cyberpunk where without
frame generation you're kind of sitting
below 100 FPS and you do notice that
smoothness quite a lot you know your
inputs will feel slightly heavier with
frame generation on because of the extra
input lag but the gameplay overall I
would say at least is improved with this
feature now of course if you already
have a game that can run at pretty high
frame rates this is a setting that you
should probably just not worry about
especially if the gameplay suffers from
that increased latency f122 for example
is another game that will support DLS S3
and frame generation again pretty decent
bump to frame rate here but for a
precise game like this you're just
better off lowering some actual quality
settings if you feel like you need that
extra frame rate now something else
that's new with the 40 series gpus is
the new nvank encoder setup so the 4090
is actually running two of the new nvank
encoders that can encode in av1 as
someone who does a bit of streaming on
the side I was personally pretty
interested to see how much of a buff
this would be compared to the nvank on
the 3090 in terms of quality there's a
pretty noticeable difference between
h.264 and the new av1 on have to pause
frames here so that YouTube compression
also doesn't get too involved but you
can see how much less blocky av-1 looks
compared to h.264 both of them here are
running 1080p 8 000 kilobits per second
with preset 1 in OBS which basically is
the fastest and lowest quality preset in
this shot here you can see how much
cleaner av1 looks and it's actually way
more noticeable when you're running
lower bit raise so preset 3 here which
is the fast kind of low to medium
quality preset and I mean it's just
night and day between h.264 and av1 even
at Just 4 000 kilobits per second
somehow av-1 just doesn't have that same
kind of blocking compression like at all
it also seems extremely good at
recognizing visual elements like shapes
outlines texts icons and stuff like that
rather than just compressing it all into
the same kind of Muddy mess now if you
feed h.264 enough bit rate and also use
the highest quality preset which would
be p7 it can look pretty good it's just
that ev1 still does all the a lot better
even with a high quality preset h.264
can still be prone to that blocking and
square compression that we're all
familiar with but to be honest I just
never saw that at all on av1 now I also
did some quick performance testing here
too in other words how much performance
or frame rate do we lose when we encode
with either preset and the results
aren't too conclusive there seems to be
about the same drop off in frame rate
between the two and similar in fact on
the previous envanc setup with the 3090
I'll probably test this a little bit
more but regardless same performance
drop off at higher quality seems to be a
pretty fair trade to me av1 encoding can
also be leveraged in video editing so
here we're looking at DaVinci Resolve
studio and the gains there are good you
know they're not as Extreme as the frame
rates that we saw earlier or the frame
generation DLS S3 but overall you're
looking at about 30 of time saved when
it comes to video exporting which for
big projects is a lot of time saved the
games in 3D rendering though are more
impressive twice the rendering speed
here of the 39 90 in blender and almost
four times faster than the 2080 TI those
gains carry right over to viru where we
see just Monster performance again both
in the RTX Benchmark and when using Kudo
but what about that huge power increase
I mean 450 Watts that's 100 Watts more
than a 3090 which is already quite
insane like yeah it's faster but it's
kind of getting a bit ridiculous now for
a consumer GPU but here's where I was
pleasantly surprised in gaming you'd be
pretty hard-pressed to get this thing
pulling the entirety of its TDP which
personally I just expected it would
because every other Nvidia GPU does that
but most of the time I saw it hovering
between 360 and 390 Watts sometimes it
did tip over that 400 watt Mark you know
depending on the game if it was
demanding enough it was only really in
fur mark that I could get it going above
that and even still it didn't pull the
full 450 Watts so that's pretty
unexpected what's also unexpected is
after running 30 minutes of furmark the
card state paid under 70 degrees C also
I'll note the memory temperatures have
been kind of fixed on the founders
edition cards previously they were
around the 90 to 100 C Mark but now
they're sitting around 80. this is all
with an ambient room temperature of 22
degrees and here's an idea of what the
card sounds like at full load
now some quick notes on overclocking I
did manage to get the 4090 close to the
three gigahertz Mark which is pretty
insane plus 220 on the core here but
ultimately that wasn't fully stable so I
lowered it to plus 200 and that was
absolutely fine somehow I also managed
plus 1700 on the memory which makes for
the fastest gddrx speeds that I've ever
seen and in the end it's about a 9 bump
to gaming performance here in God of War
of course not really a GPU that you'd
need to overclock but I mean there's a
bit more room in the tank than usual
which is always nice to see now it's
important to note that a lot of the kind
of new features that we've talked about
today like the DLS S3 frame generation
and the new av1 dual envanc encoders
that stuff will also trickle down to the
you know 4080s that have already been
announced and the 4070 when that will
come out and you know potentially the
460 when that comes out down the road as
well so don't be pressured to buy the
4090 if those are just the kind of
features that you're interested in and
especially when the 490 is just so
brutally overkill for 99 of setups out
there like I really had to stop myself
laughing at how ridiculous some of those
numbers were at you know 4K maxed out
Graphics now in terms of pricing I'm
going to say something that's maybe a
little bit unpopular but I really can't
see it any other way and that's what the
4090 isn't really an overpriced GPU now
of course the 40 80 16 gig and the 12
gig those are absolutely very overpriced
you know just looking at how that
pricing compares to the previous
generation but the 40 90 you know
compared to the 1500 3090 which was
realistically a lot more expensive than
that and the 1200 2080 TI compared the
performance of those gpus you know
spending a hundred dollars more than the
3090 you're actually getting an insanely
more powerful product I mean the kind of
performance jump from the 39 to the 40
90 again I'll just say it is absolutely
insane and of course goes without saying
it's brutally overkill for 99 of the
setups out there like you if you don't
have a 4k 144hz monitor or a 1440p 360hz
monitor that's coming out uh yeah don't
even take a second look at this GPU of
course if you want to use it for Content
creation production workloads and stuff
like that it is definitely suitable for
that stuff too but exclusively looking
at gaming performance here you need a
very very high-end gaming monitor to
even display the amount of frames that
this thing is pushing out otherwise I'll
leave some links down below for those
interested as always a huge thanks for
watching and stay tuned for a lot more
content coming up on these gpus and I'll
see you all in the next one